sébastien bovet michel david michels et
augé bonsoir bonsoir petit tour de table
quand même sur ce qui se passe aux etats
unis sont attendus suite monsieur bart
hayden qui a dit aujourd'hui d'avoir que
dit j'ai hâte de parler au président un
même s'il me reconnais pas les choses
vont aller vont avancer malgré tout et
ceux qui m'aident at il laissé
sous-entendre c'est que tous les appels
que je reçois du monde entier on écoute
michel serrault géant du web et les gens
sur la planète ont compris que c'était
réglé
oui et c'est pas mal d'années c'est
quand les pays étrangers disent bon ben
on a vu le processus aussi c'est quoi
une élection nous lequel avait à la
france garde votées en hausse à des
élections
on a vu qu'ils avaient gagné ce n'est
pas inutile bon monsieur pompeo le
secrétaire d'état dira qu'à la deuxième
administration trump mais vous savez à
chaque fois qu'ils sont allés devant les
tribunaux il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de de
cause c'est très près d'une heure mais
sans faire virer devant les tribunaux de
sa défroque c'est alors qu'on n'a pas de
preuves une malversation à cette
échelle-là ce qui serait quand même
assez spectaculaire je serai prêt d'ici
contraire c'est même un juge que dis je
ne juge pas avec des théories du complot
en mémoire des faits mais voilà on verra
michel david
ça se poursuit mais bon évidemment il
inspire le calme puis dit ne vous en
faites pas il veut rassurer aussi il
veut plaider que il va aller de l'avant
quand même
oui bien évidemment je pense pas que
monsieur tram soit vraiment impressionné
par les témoignages de les félicitations
qui viennent du monde entier de monsieur
trump se fout du monde entier mais
monsieur maiden ne peut le choix que de
préparer la suite parce qu'elle va venir
et un moment donné et c'est d'autant
plus important qu'il soit prêt et je
pense en particulier à la coved aussi ce
taux qui va prendre les rênes du pouvoir
parce que si ce temps là ça risque pas
de s'améliorer si monsieur trompe va
continuer à se comporter de la même
façon irresponsable qu il le fait depuis
le début de la pandémie alors
monsieur wade doit être prêt à entrer
maintenant à ce que ce qu'on peut
espérer c'est que la certitude que ça va
finir le 20 janv il va quand même
percolé dans la société américaine au
niveau des états des villes et qu'on va
commencer à prendre acte les règles du
jeu changent et il n'est pas trop tôt
disons pour amorcer un changement un
mois et trois jours en fait parce que
avant le 20 janvier
le 14 décembre sébastien y aura la
réunion symbolique des grands électeurs
qui vont officiellement donc voté pour
le nouveau président américain
alors là ça sera fait là alors c'est
pour ça que lui le jeune monsieur jobs
il est limitée malgré tout la dans le
tas même si haut rien pour la question
est quand même limité dante
il ya deux choses je les recomptages
dans certains états où il est et où
monsieur baden a gagné par un demi heure
2% - pour ça c'est un processus
relativement légitimement rencontre
quand la marge de victoire est
extrêmement serré puis on peut changer
les choses est ce que c'est assez pour
donner ces états là monsieur trompe pas
sur l'autre histoire celi procédure en
justice pour des votes supposément
illégaux ya aucune démonstration que il
ya eu de la fraude ou de malversation ou
des votes illégaux qui ont été
comptabilisés et si la tendance se
maintienne monsieur byden pour obtenir
trois cent six grands électeurs 306
grands électeurs c'est le même nombre
que monsieur tron avait obtenu en 2016
exact il y avait en fait obtenu 304
michel parce que deux grands électeurs
n'avaient pas voté mais l'on rangera pas
dans ces acteurs associatifs
ce n'est plus exactement ce n'est plus
le moment revenons à la coved mesures
sanitaires prolongée jusqu'au 23
novembre on n'est pas surpris sébastien
vous nous disiez hier c'est écrit dans
le ciel parce que les chiffres sont
encore trop élevés pour n'arrive pas à
baisser mais mais on remonte beaucoup
moins qu'ailleurs je fais entendre
monsieur le groupe ont rien quand on
regarde le nombre de coques par million
d'habitants il ya beaucoup de pays je
pense entre autres aux états unis à la
france à la plupart des pays en europe
où lyon 2 x 2 de corps par jour de
nouveaux cas par jour toutes proportions
gardées donc on peut se dit bon on
résiste mieux ou d'une autre manière
garde des sceaux est ce que c'est ce qui
nous attend dans les prochaines semaines
dr tremblay vient de réponde à ça si
vous l'avez entendu en disant que comme
on a été plus rapide que les européens
reconfirmer on peut échapper à cela on
ne le sait pas encore mais donc été on
n'était pas habitué on n'était vraiment
pas dans un contexte bastien où on
allait relâcher
il ya encore trop d'incertitudes et cet
extrait leur résume à 15 20 secondes la
pensée de françois legault est ce qu on
est du bon côté
ou est-ce qu'on a encore un doute sur le
côté ou dans lequel on se situe et parce
qu'il ya encore ce doute cette
incertitude que la courbe ouest est
stabilisé mais ce qu'elle pourrait
remonter on est mieux d'être plus
prudent que pas assez c'est la raison
pour laquelle il ne dit pas
d'assouplissements d'ici le 23 novembre
d'ici deux semaines on préfère en faire
plus car c'est la courbe sauver noël
d'une certaine façon que de se retrouver
dans un relâchement dans des
assouplissements oullins faudrait
apprécié avoir une comme qui remonte et
reconfirmer de nouveau certains secteurs
d'activité on veut pas jouer au yoyo et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on
maintient le statu quo chef david est ce
que c'est
est-ce que c'est convaincant comme
explication pour ne pas rouvrir un peu
les choses à montréal par exemple je
pense que oui et bien honnêtement
patrice aka monsieur au bout des quatre
premières semaines car monsieur legault
a dit on va réévaluer dans deux semaines
honnêtement
il n'y avait pas grand chance que c'est
que cette révision la se traduisent par
un assouplissement je pense monsieur
legault voulais simplement dire au
jambon désespère époque peut-être que ça
va s'améliorer mais un miracle
voilà mais je pense qu'ils savaient déjà
que ça se poursuit vers plus longtemps
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
madame tremblay écoutez le plateau alors
oui il est relativement stable de bon il
ya des petites choses à l'occasion mais
il est là ce plateau là parce que les
mesures sont intervenues et on peut
facilement penser quand le vent ces
mesures là la cour va repartir à la
autres comme comme ça se produit
ailleurs l'or vaut au canada
dans le reste du pays bas en ontario au
manitoba un peu partout en alberta c'est
reparti alors monsieur legault serait ce
le serait responsable finalement de
lever les mesures ou de les assumer même
si docteur droit et encore de la santé
publique de montréal disait il ya
quelques jours michel c les musées les
salles de spectacle les les
bibliothèques on pourrait on pourrait
desserrer un peu même si compte tenu de
sa est ce que vous croyez monsieur
legault a raison d'être plus prudent que
moins d'erreurs je pense qu'il ya
monsieur legault sexy au dessert un
petit peu des gens basée à oak hills
have a vu ça va vraiment nu donc on peut
commencer à faire telle chose à faire
peu de choses face qui veut pas envoyer
le message qu'on dessert maintenant ça
va relativement bien car lorsqu'on
compare à l'europe c'est sûr et donc il
faut maintenir ça parce que l'objectif
du gouvernement c'est de garder les
écoles ouvertes c'est de garder le
minimum qui est ouvert et tout signe de
relâchement pourrait être mal interprété
par la population qui était alors donc
il faut faire attention les écoles on
attend aujourd'hui il ya eu d'un l'on
m'a mal passé là tu sûr l'aération des
salles de classe je vends temps de
l'opposition le ministre qui répond et
monsieur dubé qui répondent qu'ils vont
regarder ça on écoute j'ai pas envie de
me signaler mais de l'éducation je
demande aux choses un état des lieux et
dès maintenant faire des commandes pour
avoir des filtres en date portable pour
la santé sécurité des enfants et du
personnel ce cas là on est en mode
rattrapage on calfeutrent les fenêtres
on change les fenêtres on change les
toits on change de système de
ventilation mécanique des fois on a
tellement d'argent investies qu'on
cherchait entrepreneurs prévoient pas de
rénover nos écoles a demandé une mise au
jour avec un comité d'experts pour être
capable de regarder la ventilation pas
uniquement dans les écoles mais dans nos
différents établissements
bon vivant ça nous renvoie au fait que
beaucoup d'écoles vétuste sébastien
alors là qu'est ce qu'on fait mais on
veut surtout pas fermer d'autres icônes
donc la solution à court terme c'est de
garder les fenêtres et les portes
ouvertes dans les salles de classe au
québec c'est la solution qui est sur la
table en ce moment imaginez au mois de
janvier au mois de février
comment ça va être les courants d'air
dans les casses moi j'aimerais ça j'aime
le froid dans les salles mais je
comprends que gelée pour étudier c'est
peut-être pas nécessairement la
meilleure combinaison mais cela étant
dit il ya un réel une réelle
préoccupation la mesure où depuis que l'
oms a dit que les aérosols des
gouttelettes qui restent en suspens dans
l'air peuvent être des transmetteurs du
virus
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans les classes
l'éclat les écoles sont vétustes au
québec est ce qu'il ya des des appareils
d'appoint tu pourrais être apportées au
delà d'ouvrir les fenêtres ou d'ouvrir
les portes et même semble-t-il des
classes dans lesquelles il n'y a pas de
fenêtre ou des classes dans lesquelles
les fenêtres s'ouvrent alors c'est un
problème et c'est une discussion qui en
ce moment mais michel david encore un
autre exemple on est rattrapé par notre
retard d'avoir laissé pendant des années
des années des années des années les
écoles dans un mauvais état
absolument et on parle là des écoles
mais souvenez-vous il ya quelques années
quand les viaducs sont mis à tomber l'on
s'est rendu compte qu'on avait réparé
depuis des dizaines d'années c'est le
cas des hôpitaux le c'est le cas des
écoles et ça renforce encore dans mon
esprit la nécessité de maintenir les
mesures parce que étant donné qu'avec
l'hiver la circulation les fenêtres vont
se fermer la circulation devrait être
moins - la propagation du virus va va
être plus grande
alors
raison de plus pour que la contagion
communautaire et
sk - disons de d'andré dans les écoles
alors que tout ça se tient là on peut
pas dire bon bain les écoles c'est pas
grave
et puis non quand il faut agir à tous
les niveaux cohérents
vous êtes un beau comme il nous reste
deux temps par je voulais parler du
tramway absolument
michel sait vous aimez le transport en
commun est ce qui se présente devant le
bape compliqué mais pas le rush et que
vous étiez peut-être un peu d'accord
avec ça mais le bape qui dit j'aime pas
le projet du tramway
le gouvernement de la caq doivent être
très bien on franc on recommence à zéro
qu'est ce que vous comprenez de ça je
comprends qu'il ya plusieurs députés de
la caq dans la légende québec qui n'ont
jamais aimé ce projet nord ce projet là
il divise beaucoup les gens pour des
années longtemps pour comprendre ça et
beaucoup de députés de la caq a commencé
dans la vie on n'aime pas ce projet là
et se répondent particulièrement fâché
si ce projet était abandonné ou modifier
substantiellement alors je comprends
aussi frustration du maire qui a
travaillé très fort là dessus et qu'il a
su saisir
recommencez donc vous de voir il serait
tenté de dire une autre fois parce que
il les a fait souvent ses devoirs sur ce
à un moment donné l'addition qu'il faut
le gouvernement à prendre c est ce qu on
le veut le tramway où on ne veut pas et
c'est lui qui m'a décidée par celui qui
va le financer
une fois qu'on aura plus cette décision
de principe là l'on pourra peut-être
parler de certains tracés aussi et ça
mais si ça vient de la petite politique
avec des députés de la lointaine
banlieue de la plus lointaine banlieue
de québec qui disent ah ben moi si j'ai
pas le très branché notre pays ça marche
pas d'abord coin on n'en finira jamais
michel david
j'en ai tous les trucs il ya quand même
des éléments dans le rapport du bape qui
sont pertinents à mon sens si ça diminue
pas l'achalandage parce que les gens des
banlieues vont venir en voiture de toute
façon il ya un problème que
le tramway ne
connecte pas avec les gars par exemple
qui sont qui sont pas bien loin de la
gare du palais s'est placé au centre
ville
ça n'a pas de bon sens ça doit
s'arranger
ben j'imagine que ça peut s'arranger
mais vous savez à toutes les fois qu'on
arrange quelque chose la facture
augmente et là on est à un point 8
milliards de participation du
gouvernement du québec sur les trois
points 3 milliards au total
si on commence à zibello faudrait
changer si pas longer ça ça montre
extrêmement vite et ce qui est ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est la connexion
avec le troisième ligne
et encore là je vois mal comment ça peut
se justifie qu'un concombre et comme
l'espèce deux projets le kiki sont ainsi
loué qui connecte pas mais c'était prévu
ce avec un train sébastien dans le
troisième vient y avait pas
nécessairement de trait sur le troisième
il y avait le projet structurant du
jusqu'au troisième but avec des débuts
ce qui aurait circulé sur le troisième
ligne le problème c'est que le
gouvernement met plein de critères puis
il espère qu'avec le budget de 3,3
milliards on va arriver à répondre à ces
critères la desservir les bonus vous
désormais les banlieues ça allonge le
tracé puis ça coûte encore plus cher
le lay l'interconnexion avec le
troisième y est ça rallonge aussi le
principe d'une certaine façon c'est on
se demande en effet si le gouvernement y
tient au tramway et à ce projet
structurant publiquement il dit que oui
mais il émet des conditions qui fait en
sorte que c'est dur de le livrer avec
les conditions et les critères émis par
le gouvernement sur la banque doit être
découragés ce qui va rester ce qui va se
représenter que juste pour ça c'est un
des grands mystères de québec pour l'est
il a évoqué pour la première fois la
semaine et la fin de semaine dernière
qu'il n'était pas et remplaçable après
rester après je suis resté après la
pause une surprise pour vous pressez
vous 3 au 6 mai jour ouvert a pas tout
de suite